[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi di voi non ha mai guardato il cielo
stellato meravigliandosi della sua
bellezza e sentendosi fortunato a poter
ammirare un panorama simile
chi di voi non si è mai chiesto come
questo quadro magnifico abbia avuto
origine e sia cambiato col tempo sapere
è una necessità per l'uomo e un
astrofisico per lavoro cerca di
rispondere a queste domande
interpretando osservazioni fatte sia
dallo spazio che da terra con telescopi
sempre più sofisticati grazie a queste
osservazioni
oggi sappiamo che nell'universo visibile
ci sono più di 100 miliardi di galassie
tutte diverse tra di loro in forme
dimensioni e storie ma tutte le formate
da polvere stelle e gas
la nostra galassia la via lattea
contiene tra 200 e 400 miliardi di
stelle circondate da almeno 100 miliardi
di pianeti
una tra queste stelle è il nostro sole
ea girare intorno al sole
ci siamo noi sull'unico pianeta del
sistema solare su cui sia stata trovata
vita intelligente almeno nella media tra
tutti i pianeti del sistema solare
siamo gli unici ad avere un satellite
enorme rispetto a noi con un quarto del
raggio della terra e un ottantesimo
della sua massa la luna illumina le
nostre notti regolari maree e stabilizza
l'inclinazione dell'asse terrestre
contribuendo a regalarci le stagioni o
almeno quello che ne resta
dati i cambiamenti climatici in atto e
quindi contribuisce alla possibilità
della vita sulla terra
quante volte l'abbiamo ammirata in cielo
e quanto l'abbiamo data per scontata
eppure sappiamo
che si sta allontanando da noi di quasi
4 centimetri all'anno si pensa che sia
nata molto più vicino alla terra a soli
25 mila chilometri da noi
ed oggi si trova a ben 384 mila
chilometri dalla terra la luna ha
ispirato innumerevoli miti e leggende e
con le sue fasi a sulle sue fasi si
basano calendari e religioni con le sue
regioni chiare scure che sono visibili
ad occhio nudo è sempre stata
considerata un corpo celeste ribelle
perché non era la sfera liscia e
perfetta della cosmologia aristotelica
nel 1600 soltanto galilei anche lui un
ribelle che non si fermava le apparenze
col suo cannocchiale riuscire ad
osservarne nel dettaglio la superficie a
scoprirne finalmente le sue terre i suoi
mari e i suoi rilevamenti montuosi
però facciamo un passo avanti nel tempo
e torniamo al giorno d'oggi e troviamo
un altro evento storico fondamentale il
20 luglio 1969 il primo uomo mette piede
sulla luna e da li guarda il nostro
pianeta blu il primo uomo su un altro
corpo celeste
da lì in poi molte altre missioni apollo
sono atterrati sulla luna e ci hanno
riportato indietro delle preziosissime
rocce extraterrestri questo punto è
importantissimo e ci tornerà utile
più tardi però nonostante tutti questi
prodigi della scienza e della guerra
fredda ancora sapevamo poco di come si
fosse formato il nostro satellite
per capirlo dobbiamo fare un altro passo
indietro nel tempo
dobbiamo andare 4 miliardi e mezzo di
anni fa
a quel punto il sole si era appena
formato ed era circondato da un disco di
polvere e gas che gli orbitavano attorno
come prima cosa dal gas
si formarono i giganti giove saturno
urano e nettuno poi rimase soltanto
polvere di dimensioni infinitesimali
e questa polvere mentre girava intorno
al sole cominciò a scontrarsi e ad
aggregarsi e a formare delle rocce di
dimensioni chilometriche queste rocce
poi iniziarono a scontrarsi tra di loro
e ad aggregarsi anche loro
grazie anche alla stessa forza di
gravità che ci tiene coi piedi per terra
e finalmente da questi scontri
nacquero i pianeti rocciosi mercurio
venere la nostra terra marte e perfino
il piccolo scoglio che fino a una decina
di anni fa veniva chiamato pianeta
plutone la terra appena formata era
completamente diversa da oggi era una
sfera di magma in cui i metalli e rocce
erano mescolati tra di loro e
innumerevoli corpi celesti la
bombardavano la colpivano noncuranti del
potenziale effetto distruttivo che
potevano avere però la nostra terra ce
l'ha fatta è sopravvissuta fino
all'ultimo impatto gigante che ha subito
con un pianeta delle dimensioni di marte
che chiamiamo teja come la madre di
selene nella mitologia greca questo
pianeta
in questo scontro fu completamente
distrutto e formò un disco di detriti
intorno alla terra
questi detriti in un processo simile a
quello della formazione dei pianeti
rocciosi cominciarono ad aggregarsi tra
di loro e da qui pensiamo che si sia
formata la nostra luna vi ricordate
delle rocce di cui vi parlavo prima
riportati indietro dalle missioni apollo
non sono state lasciate in un museo ma
sono state analizzate nel dettaglio e da
queste analisi
oggi sappiamo che la luna e la terra
sono praticamente identiche dal punto di
vista geologico però c'è un problema dai
meteoriti che ci sono arrivati dallo
spazio sappiamo che i pianeti del
sistema solare sono molto diversi
chimicamente tra di loro quindi com'è
possibile che tra lo scontro
tra due pianeti potenzialmente così
diversi tra di loro la terra e taglia
sia nata una luna praticamente uguale
alla terra
però quando si fa senza avere un
problema non è vista come una cosa
negativa anzi è vista come
un'opportunità l'opportunità di scoprire
qualcosa di nuovo perché se non ci
fossero domande non ci sarebbe motivo di
pensare di calcolare di fare teorie e
quindi non ci sarebbe il progresso nella
mia vita di tutti i giorni mi occupo di
ammassi stellari che contengono fino a
decine di milioni di stelle ed enormi
buchi neri però per rispondere alla
domanda sulla formazione della luna e
sulla sua composizione chimica mi sono
trasformata per un momento in una
planetologa e io sono sempre stata una
fan delle trasformazioni e infatti come
sa chi mi conosce bene
sailor moon era ed è ancora la mia
eroina preferita
a quel punto mi sono occupata di una
sola stella il sole del nostro pianeta
la terra del suo salento e satellite la
luna un sistema complicatissimo
nonostante le sue piccole dimensioni e
per farlo ha utilizzato centinaia di
simulazioni della formazione del nostro
sistema solare molto simili a quelle che
usa ogni giorno per studiare il modo
delle stelle in queste situazioni o
migliaia di rocce che girano intorno al
sole e che si scontrano e che formano i
pianeti rocciosi e tra questi pianeti ho
potuto individuare la terra e teglia e
confrontare la loro composizione chimica
da questo confronto con i miei colleghi
abbiamo scoperto che la formazione di
una luna uguale alla terra non è poi
così probabile avviene in meno del 40
per cento degli impatti che osserviamo
nelle nostre simulazioni però è molto
più probabile di quello che si pensava
in passato meno dell'un per cento quando
con i miei colleghi abbiamo trovato
questo risultato ci siamo guardati
abbiamo pensato wow
ecco la soluzione la luna
è il frutto di una catena di eventi
possibile
esiste una sola luna come la nostra
perché questi eventi non succedono
sempre dunque la terra aveva una gemella
teglia che si era formata vicina alla
terra e con composizione chimica simile
alla terra e che scontrando la terra era
rimasta distrutta e aveva dato vita alla
nostra luna risolvere un problema
scoprire qualcosa di nuovo
contribuire al sapere comune è una cosa
entusiasmante essere l'astrofisica è
difficile a volte noioso come ogni altro
lavoro
però quando appunto quando risolve un
problema o contribuisco la soluzione di
un enigma semplicemente discute in modo
costruttivo con i miei colleghi
provo una soddisfazione che posso solo
chiamare passione ecco allora la
prossima volta che guarderete la luna in
cielo pensatela come alla nostra piccola
gemella il frutto di uno di quei tanti
eventi che accadono continuamente
nell'universo e di cui sappiamo ancora
così poco una gemella di cui oggi
sappiamo qualcosa in più molti altri
sono gli enigmi che intrigano ogni mio
giornata ricercatrice da archeologa
delle stelle però farsi domande non è
prerogativa degli scienziati fa parte
della natura umana ed è per questo che
non dobbiamo mai smettere di chiederci
cosa ci sia dietro quello che vediamo
adesso che siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo nostro viaggio
ricordiamoci sempre di stimolare la
nostra curiosità quella dei nostri figli
di chi ci circonda perché scoprire
scoprire capire è un piacere che nessuno
mai dovrebbe negarsi
[Applauso]